welcome to the man of Recaps this is the
live action One Piece season one welcome
to a world that is mostly ocean and so
naturally it's full of pirates 20 years
ago the pirate king gold Roger was
captured but with his last words he told
the crowd of his hidden treasure horde
they called the one piece because I
guess it's all in one piece gold Roger
was executed but he inspired a whole new
generation to become Pirates and hunt
for the one piece but 20 years later no
one has found it so we follow a new
hopeful Monkey D Luffy he's a
happy-go-lucky energetic youngster with
unshakable confidence that he will find
the one piece and become the new king of
the Pirates he's knocked off to a very
good start as his boat sinks and he's
picked up by the evil pirate alvida yeah
by the way there are no normal pirates
on this show they all have to have some
Wild theme a prisoner on the ship is the
unconfident Kobe but Luffy befriends him
and stands up for him Luffy is a decent
fighter especially because he has
stretchy Powers yes as a kid he ate a
devil fruit that turned his body into
rubber so he calls out his finishing
move gum gum pistol and knocks alvita
out of there yalufi wants to be a good
pirate like his childhood Idol
red-haired Shanks who saved him from a
sea monster but lost his arm Shanks gave
Luffy his iconic straw hat like come
find me when you're a famous pirate
yourself now to find a one-piece Luffy
needs a map and maps are pretty rare in
this world so they go to a Marine base
to try to steal one but here he meets a
couple other characters with anime main
character energy because they have
brightly colored hair there's the pirate
Hunter Zorro a master swordsman who
carries three swords but he only pulls
the third out for his special occasions
he gets in a fight with the spoiled son
of the Marine Commander which lands him
in jail but as Luffy sneaks into the
Marine base he gives him a Spiel on
Monkey D Luffy gonna be king of the
Pirates and sets him free you should
join my crew also sneaking into the
Marine base is the orange-haired Nami
who's a thief looking to steal a map
herself the map they need is a real
special one kept in the commander safe
and long story short they get it out
there but now they gotta fight the whole
Marine base all three of them working
together Luffy's crew has assembled the
Nami and Zorro don't admit it yet but
now they fight the commander himself ax
hand Morgan who does indeed have an ax
for a hand for the boss fight Zorro
pulls out his third sword which he holds
in his mouth which is utterly ridiculous
but he makes it work as they make their
escape Kobe he's not coming he doesn't
want to be a pirate he wants to be a
marine Luffy's biggest thing is
supporting people following their dreams
so we may be on opposite sides of the
law but I know we can still be friends
so Luffy and Friends sail away and they
become known as the straw hat Pirates
now what makes this map so special
Navigator Nami explains the ocean
world's divided into four quadrants with
a big strip of land running down the
middle and around the equator is the
grand line the most wild Untamed
dangerous place on the planet the map
they stole is the only known map of the
grand line so it's very special so our
little crew has caught the attention of
marine vice admiral GARP and yes by the
way phones in the show are snails and
also garp's hat is a dog he's gonna lead
a squad of new recruits to hunt down
these Straw Hat Pirates including Kobe
and axan Sun who now has an atrocious
haircut given to him by Zoro when he
escaped and it's not just the Marines
other Pirates are after them too the
first of which is buggy the clown pirate
and buggy is kind of funny but he's also
bad and he recognizes Luffy's Straw Hat
yes he used to be friends with Shanks
but it didn't end well and Luffy can't
just beat this guy with his stretchy
Powers because he ate the devil fruit 2
The Chop Chop fruit that lets him break
into pieces he puts Luffy in a sea water
tank yes that's the problem with devil
fruit sea water nullifies your powers
and makes you weak but Luffy's crew
breaks him out of there and they figure
out to lock Buggy's Parts in the
different chests so now he's no longer a
threat now our crew needs a new boat and
Luffy can't steal one stealing is wrong
I'm not sure he knows what a pirate is
at Luffy's favorite boat he meets usop a
guy who exaggerates every story he tells
he claims he's best friends with the
boat's owner but turns out it's true
it's the young woman Kaia she loves his
obviously fake stories of the Great
Captain usop because they make her laugh
she invites him to stay for her birthday
dinner but her Butler does not approve
and soon Spirits her away because of her
poor health but turns out he is the
pirate Kuro leader of the black cat
Pirates and Kai is not really sick he's
been slowly poisoning her this whole
time as an evil plan to take all her
money usop fights with his signature
slingshot but Kuro super fast oh he ate
devil fruit too uzop tries to warn the
village of the Pirate Invasion but they
don't listen to him it's the boy who
cried wolf because his whole life he's
been saying the Pirates are coming when
he was a kid his dad left to become a
pirate and he always hoped that his dad
would come back and turns out out Luffy
knows who stops dad he was part of
shanks's crew but Kobe's here with the
novice Marines but kugo convinces him
that usop's a liar he hands over Luffy
though who is mostly dead because he
drank the entire poison soup yeah
Luffy's favorite thing is food but now
Luffy barfs it up he's totally fine so
Luffy steps in to fight this guy and
he's normally a happy kid but the one
thing you don't do is mess with his
friends so Luffy goes into beast mode
gum gum Bell and knocks this guy out of
here as thanks for saving her Kaya gives
them the boat and usop's gonna come join
the crew have the real Adventures of the
Great Captain usop even though Luffy of
course is the real Captain but now the
Marines have caught up to them and when
Luffy sees GARP he says Grandpa yes
young Luffy always wanted to be a pirate
but his vice admiral Grandpa did not
approve so yes this Hunt is a Family
Feud uh Luffy bounces The Cannonball
back so they escape they come to the
Pirate restaurant baratier which is of
course Luffy's dream and back in the
kitchen is a Master Chef it's Sanji but
his boss doesn't approve of him going
off menu so he makes him a waiter today
where he meets our crew and flirts with
nami but now garps and someone else
after Luffy a pirate himself dracul
mihok he's one of the seven Warlords of
the sea legendary pirates that are
pardoned by the world government because
it's too hard to go after them and
better to let them take out other
Pirates mihawk is famously the greatest
swordsman alive so Zorro stands up and
challenges him to a duel that's his
backstory he made a vow with his best
friend to become the greatest swordsman
alive but she died in a tragic accident
and that's his third sword it belonged
to her so to proof he's the best he's
gotta beat mihawk but mihawk pulls out
his tiny little knife and yeah this guy
is on a whole nother level even with
zoro's third mouth sword he beats him
handily he breaks his other two but
zoro's pretty good so mihawk slashes him
just deep enough that he'll Live come
face me again when you're ready as for
Luffy he's interested by this kid's
spark I'm gonna let you go and see what
you get up to but now hunting Luffy is
the pirate arlong captain of The Fish
Man Crew He tracked Luffy here because
he found Buggy's head who had an ear in
Luffy's hat the whole time and Luffy
can't beat our long fish men are really
strong and pretty soon things look Bleak
but he saved by Nami who's like hey our
long I got the map for you oh she's been
on his crew this whole time but Luffy
doesn't believe Nami really betrayed
them he knows there's something else
going on and is gonna go to rescue her
and sailing out with him is the suited
Jeff Sanji his dream is to find the
all-blue a legendary restaurant with
ingredients from all four C's as a kid
he was captured by his Future boss who
at the time was the captain of the
dreaded Chef Pirates when the ship sank
they were Maroons together they split up
the food the adult took the bigger bag
because he's an adult but turns out
there was no food in there he gave it
all to Sanji and to survive ate his own
leg Yeah Chef zeff is a real good guy
and these two fight constantly but they
love each other so we go to arlong's
headquarters at the ruined Cocoa Village
which was where a young Nami grew up
until arlong invaded and killed her
mother but then Nami betrayed her people
and joined our Long's crew now she comes
and collects tribute from him there's
something up Nami I know you're a good
person she claims not to be but of
course she is she joined arlong's crew
as part of a promise that if she gave
him a hundred million Berry that's the
word for money by the way she could buy
back Cocoa Village and he'd leave it in
peace and finally nami's collected
enough but our long goes back on the
deal sends the corrupt Marines on his
payroll after her so Nami is devastated
goes to cut off her tattoo but her
Captain Luffy is there to help her
you're gonna help me even though I
betrayed you and he puts his straw hat
on her of course I will so the straw hat
Pirates bust into arlong's pool party
and it's a big anime fight Sanji by the
way only fights by kicking buggy agreed
to help them if they get his body back
but he was lying he pieces out Luffy
goes to fight arlong and he's real mad
that he messed with his friend Nami are
long still way too strong Luffy can't
win but it's the maps that Nami had
drawn for him that will let him rule the
Seas and start his Fishman Empire so
Luffy's gonna destroy his map room and
he goes for the Epic big kick gum gum
battle ax wow knocks are along all the
way down destroys the whole building but
it's not over yet cause Grandpa's caught
up to him Kobe steps forward hey Luffy's
clearly the good guy here I refuse to
follow orders bad haircut joins too he's
become kind of a better person and best
friends with Cody but GARP doesn't need
them he'll do it himself cause oh
grandpa packs a big Wallop he grabs his
grandson stop fooling around but Monkey
D Luffy knows exactly who he is he's
gonna find the one piece and become king
of the Pirates so GARP gives up all
right kid you win I'm proud of you at
least for following your own dream but
next time I see you I'll have to arrest
you cause indeed Luffy has achieved one
dream he finally got his own wanted
poster he says goodbye to his Marine
friend Kobe they've realized that there
can be bat Marines and good Pirates so
they both vow to be good and GARP was
impressed that he stood up for what's
right so he's taken the bad haircut Duo
to be his personal apprentices but
Luffy's new fame makes him a big Target
for all his former villains who he
doesn't kill so they can all come back
and also watch out for a mysterious
figure who smokes two cigars at the same
time and also watch out for the bad guy
group Baroque Works who tried to recruit
Zorro at the beginning of the season but
he turned them down but Luffy has
friends out there too like red-haired
Shanks who is still alive mihawk visits
him like Hey I'm at Luffy and look he's
become a real pirate and our crew has
become a family they all make a vow to
follow their dreams and the straw hat
Pirates unveil their new flag yeah The
Smiling skeleton with the straw hat so
Monkey D Luffy is really doing it gonna
go to the Grand line find the one piece
and become king of the Pirates and
that's where season one comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
foreign